foreign
foreign
thank you
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but shakes
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers and elephants and bathrooms
the elements of bathrooms what on Earth
is going on with Trump and toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation a big massive dumps
and bathrooms
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms
[Music]
Alex Jones
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shoulders
[Music]
what's your password
[Music]
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too nonsense okay now
that we are up under our bodies
my bag of mangoes now cost
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
pray my man goes back down
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified from the
mangoes
be affected
all right I'm cutting it I'm having that
weird issue where there's like it's
playing twice and it's just a complete
and total technical disaster over here I
really don't know why that setting just
reverts on its own in stream Labs but it
is completely humiliating and for that I
apologize to everybody
extraordinarily seriously we have
incredible news today New York and
Leticia James are suing Donald Trump and
his company and his family and they are
sending a criminal referral that's right
a criminal referral that's right
a criminal referral yes
to the IRS and other elements of law
enforcement take a look at this CNBC
article and we're going to get all of
the details and we are going to uh hear
from Michael Cohen and Trump is untruth
Central and it's all completely Bonkers
New York sues Donald Trump company and
family members over widespread fraud
claims
seeks at least 250 million dollars in
penalties
New York attorney general Leticia James
on Wednesday sued former president
Donald Trump the Trump Organization
three of his adult children and others
for allegedly widespread fraud involving
false financial statements related to
the company
indeed the lawsuit seeks at least 250
million dollars in Damages the complaint
says Mr Trump's statements of financial
condition for the period 2011-2021 were
fraudulent and misleading in their
composition and presentation there is a
220-page civil lawsuit filed in
Manhattan Supreme Court I encourage you
to take a look at it it seeks to this is
just beautiful it seeks to permanently
bar Trump Don Jr Eric Trump and Ivanka
from serving as officers of a company in
New York and permanently ban the Trump
companies named in the suit from doing
business in the state
this is absolutely fantastic
uh James said she has asked Federal
prosecutors in Manhattan and the IRS
this is this is a beautiful line to
investigate Trump for possible federal
crimes
she said evidence obtained during the
three-year civil probe of trump
indicated possible crimes of bank fraud
and making false statements to financial
institutions this is absolutely great
stuff
new NBC New York
has another interesting article Donald
Trump sued for fraud by New York
attorney general with criminal referral
to the IRS ladies and gentlemen it is
beginning and I want to make sure
everybody is crystal clear on this like
a police of a plate glass that is
completely transparent
this is completely separate from the FBI
raid at Mar-A-Lago
it this is completely unrelated this is
another element of legal trouble that's
a totally different thing oh are people
trolling
are we are we dealing with massive dumps
of trolls in the chat that's okay well
we'll deal with it we'll deal with it
moderators know exactly what to do the
New York attorney general's office filed
a blockbuster fraud suit against Trump
and his children the suit alleges more
than 200 instances of fraud over the
course of a decade purportedly intended
to obtain more favorable loan terms or
tax benefits so I've explained this
before
you might if you don't know why Trump
would lie or what what the whole point
of this is here's here's the point
let's say I have a building it's not a
perfect building okay but it's a good
building and the building is genuinely
worth 10 million dollars okay that's
what like an appraiser would actually
believe the building is worth
if I want to get a loan for 15 million
dollars and I go okay well let's see uh
uh I want 15 million and I can only get
an 80 loan to value ratio so if the
building's worth 10 million they'll only
give me an 8 million dollar loan oh I
know I'll tell them hey here's a
building worth 20 million dollars I only
need 15 as a loan so you inflate the
value when you want to use the building
as collateral Fair
so then the real estate uh property tax
assessor comes to you and says well it's
a 20 million dollar building it's at
least 10. and you go no no no no no no
no no
here's documentation explaining why you
know you gotta flush the toilets 10 to
15 times and it's just it's a bad
building everything's covered in Gold
you know just it's a bad building this
building's only worth four million
dollars so you should only assess me for
tax purposes at four million dollars but
Sir with tears in my eyes you told us
this building was actually worth 20 well
you told the bank it was worth 20
million yeah but that's because I wanted
the loan so that's the fraud that is
being alleged here among a whole bunch
of other different things and it's going
to be a complete and total train wreck
and I completely look forward to it
we're going to look at a clip in a
moment let me look at a few of the super
chats that are coming in an incredibly
generous 69 Super Chat from s Perez who
says massive dumps of trolls worse than
pack cord are we dealing with a uh
are we dealing with a trolling problem
and if so where
oh wow so we actually got down to a very
low number for US of uh twitch Subs
because it's been a there's been a
dearth of streaming but s Prez just
dumped in 69 subscriptions I also want
to say thanks to Ryan carleo cameratages
tulmu both staff and brains Sam the
sleaze bag Polo Dal as well as small
fuzzy Moss Bobby Milo wild Cody
wow that's a lot of people that puts us
at 80 already and we've only just
started the stream also a huge thank you
to Corey Wood
Joshua Parnell Wesley Arnold and Peyton
Cole who just got memberships at
joinpakman.com folks we're at 84 already
I will stream the Trump rally Friday if
we get to 150. Trump rally Friday and
then I've got about a dozen other
possible streams scheduled for uh the
rest of this month in October many
debates fetterman V Oz demings V Rubio
Kelly V Masters uh Vance or is it JP
Mandel I forget Vance versus Ryan all of
these debates are happening because it
is election season and I'm looking
forward to very very strong streams with
y'all with all of you thanks also to
vaderate vaderette and Vic Isaac for the
twitch Prime subscriptions all right
let's continue our good friend Michael
Cohen
tweeted about the decision from Leticia
James I just uh Michael Cohen called me
the other day we are very very strongly
lining up his next appearance Michael
Cohen has a new book and he's going to
be on the program and Michael Cohen said
you know what the quickest way to get
this done is for me to personally call
David packman and we caught up about
everything and uh he tweeted I want to
personally thank Leticia James for
acknowledging my participation and
assistance in bringing accountability to
the Mandarin Mussolini I pretend I
prefer mango Mussolini myself
my journey to the truth has been filled
with sadness pain and anger today's
announcement makes it all worth it let's
listen to the announcement from Leticia
James Mr Trump and his allies
allies were that this is part of a Witch
Hunt
I will remind everyone that this
investigation only started after Michael
Cohen the former lawyer his former
lawyer testified before Congress
shed light on this misconduct
and the remedies are consistent
but what we have sought for other
businesses that committed the same
misconduct
Mr Trump very good
so very very important stuff we then saw
Donald Trump on his failing social media
platform truth essential just completely
losing it about what's going on here he
started with another Witch Hunt by a
racist attorney general Leticia James
who failed in her run for governor
getting almost zero support from the
public and now is doing poorly against
Law and Order AG candidate highly
respected Michael Henry I never thought
this case would be brought until I saw
her really bad poll numbers she is a
fraud who campaigned on a get Trump
platform despite the fact that the city
is one of the crime and murder disasters
of the world under her watch
uh continuing with attorney general
Leticia peekaboo James a total
crime-fighting disaster in New York is
spending all of her time fighting for
very powerful and well represented Banks
and insurance companies who were fully
paid made a lot of money and never had a
complaint about me instead of fighting
murder and violent crime which is
killing New York State she is a failed
AG whose lack of talent in the fight
against Crime is causing record numbers
of peoples and companies to flee New
York bye-bye
he sounds triggered to me
he sounds triggered and then lastly the
New York Times her peek-a-boo James case
against him could be difficult to prove
property valuations are often subjective
and the financial statements include a
very strong disclaimer
so Donald Trump flipping out on Truth
sensual and we are of course monitoring
CNN here uh on a number of different
things now let's get caught up on a few
other things first and foremost s press
has just gifted another 69 twitch
subscriptions putting us at 155 locking
in
a Friday Trump stream okay locking in a
Friday Trump stream
uh the next stream on the table
is the following Friday it's the Abbott
versus Beto debate okay the goal is now
250 if we get to 250 we will lock in the
Abbott versus Beto debate I also want to
say thanks to Shayna but it's my HIPAA
Danny Darko and crowbars forever as well
as Napa skip dog putting us at 160 and I
want to remind everybody indict is
today's coupon code we all know what the
meaning of the coupon code indict is and
you can sign up on my website
joinpakman.com all right super chats
Denver McCarthy says you're unblinking
guest todays
anti-contraception position makes a lot
of sense from the standpoint of biblical
yeah you guys want to see this this is
something else check this out this is a
guy I interviewed today this has not
been published yet let's see we did a
lot about voter fraud supposed
um
check this out though at one point it
got to contraception let's just listen
to this okay
oh wait hold on it's muted unmute
Adam listen I I gotta I want to get some
some other topics one of the things I
found super interesting was at one point
you wrote you would outlaw
contraceptives if you were given that
opportunity do I have that right and why
would you do that
well conveniently enough uh you you
don't have it correct okay the New York
Post I believe it was
um was that where that there's I don't
have the source in front of me I read a
bunch of stuff before I interviewed him
yeah uh I I did not write that
um they asked me what I believed
personally yeah and I said very clearly
that I believe that life begins a
conception or body is your choice and
you make a decision before conception
happens okay you and I are adults we
know how children are come to this world
and if you make a choice there's a
consequence for that choice I personally
believe that stopping the natural
progression of Life which you again made
a decision
in order to engage in sexual activity
right as a person as an individual that
is something that I believe is wrong to
stop Life as a as a representative I'm
not going to put the lid back on
Pandora's Box okay so you wouldn't move
to ban contraception but you're against
it you in other words you believe even a
condom is stopping the process of life
personally yeah I'm talking about you
personally I know it's just you
personally
well there's a difference between policy
and personally yeah so so personally yes
I believe that you are this is
completely Bonkers just if you're not oh
people talking about masturbation
trust me I get to that topic with him
just just just buckle up actually just
making a decision to engage in an
activity and you want to remove the
consequence and this applies not just to
uh oral contraceptives and plan B but
you're saying even a condom is
interfering with is it is it God's will
that you find what is it religiously
based or where are you coming up with
this uh no I I'm saying you're trying to
remove the consequence for your decision
you want to enjoy an activity that you
have a physical pleasure yeah and you
removing the consequence that is
wouldn't that apply also to for example
wearing a seat belt in a car where the
natural consequence of driving fast
might be that you get hurt in an
accident and the seat belt is
artificially keeping you uh safe I mean
it's sort of weird argument isn't it
it's a weird argument safe uh safety and
saving a life versus ending a life to me
is a an interesting but you consider
wearing a condom to be ending a life
well you're preventing a life right so
why it's it's deferring a consequence
that's what I'm saying wow that's
interesting that's right I've never I've
honestly I've heard right Wingers say
Insurance shouldn't cover some of these
things but I've never heard anyone say
that condoms are just straight up wrong
that's so you're saying that view it's
not based on your religious beliefs
no I I believe that like David think
about life if life doesn't begin a
conception if you don't defend life at
all stages yeah whether it be your end
what what partner at what point does
life have value well you're not with if
you're using a condom there's been no
conception right you're going even
earlier
what happens at the end of life sir if
you're telling me that we'd like to have
um no consequences for any decision that
you make that's what you're telling me
that we would like to have plan B well I
decided to have sex right that's how
that's how conception happens
I would like to defer that consequence
I'm not going to say the government's
going to legislate anybody know what
he's talking about and as a legislator
at this point I don't even know what
he's talking about later wow that this
is mind-blowing Adam I've never heard
this from anyone I mean you may be in
some way the most uh socially
conservative person no condoms that and
and you so how old were you when you
came to this view this anti-condom View
hahaha
when you say 80 condom again makes it
kind of sound funny well it is very
funny I think I mean it's it's very
you're saying we have to defend our life
and like are you is masturbation wrong
can I ask that
is masturbation wrong right because then
you're talking about millions of
potential lives that are no never going
to get a chance
as as an individual yeah all as an
individual
well I I have been taught and I have
come to the conclusion in my life yeah
that I I believe that you are enjoying
um an activity that's there's nothing
wrong with it but at the end of the day
you you are actually like you said you
are stuffing out life but I have nothing
out life can you imagine this guy
you want this guy figuring out what your
taxes should be wow
probation is is illegal sir wow
Adam we are treading incredible new
ground here I have to say this is good
this is going to be I can't think of a
more interesting note on which we would
end than that
um but this is really giving me a lot of
uh a lot to think about I think for lack
of a better term
um the election at this point the look
on his face is like what what the hell
did I just say it is in November Adam
Steen is running to represent District
63 in the Wisconsin State Assembly he
has been endorsed by Donald Trump we
don't know whether Donald Trump is on
the same page on some of the condom
stuff I think it would be interesting to
to talk
oh God
all right anyway I think you guys kind
of get the picture of this one
um it was a really really weird
interview really really strange stuff
so that was that and the whole thing
will be released very very soon
um northern perspective says I should
stream live if Elise stefanic accepts a
debate with Matt castelli poll numbers
have the number three Republican in the
house died with Tide with stefanik
castelli 46 okay yeah that sounds
interesting too
uh what are these you must pay for must
pay consequences for your behavior
conservatives think about Trump who has
never paid a consequence in his life oh
they believe Trump doesn't deserve any
consequence that's easy you're not going
to get them with that
I'm going to get them with that
thanks to Greg for the twitch Prime
subscription putting us at 161 as we
claw our way back to 2000 twitch
subscribers from what is currently a
very very low number I also want to say
thank you to Felicia Cortez
Liz Jennings and Brandon spagniolo for
signing up at joinpakman.com also here's
a little bonus for you guys we have a
new David Pacman show bumper sticker If
you look below me right now that's the
old Pacman show logo we just don't have
an update here on this thing okay
um
the new logo we have not had on bumper
stickers we are now giving away free
bumper stickers to anyone who gets a
membership on the website using the
coupon code sticker you save a little
bit with the coupon code but you get a
completely free membership shipped at a
free free bumper sticker shipped
anywhere in the world okay so join
pacman.com coupon code sticker for a
free sticker I have two little projects
where we could use some help if we have
some technically inclined people in the
audience number one is we need some new
live stream overlays
that not only integrate the new logo but
we just need a refresh of the overlays
okay so that's one thing sometimes
people say hey Dave I have Tech skills
elements of tech that would be great and
number two we do need a new studio
design expert and this is both the
technical and the backdrops because we
are getting very close to moving into
the new studio now and it is time we
know the dimensions of the room but we
now need to know we need someone who can
help with the tech and with the set
Tech and set so if anybody and we're
glad to hire right I mean it doesn't
have to be free you don't have to give
away uh your your time but um
if I mean you know whatever but we're
glad to pay or if someone wants to
donate some assistance on that that's
fine but get in touch info
davidpackman.com new overlays and then
Studio
uh Studio Design all very very exciting
things all right let's continue because
there is so much going on
um s Prez dumping in another 69 super
chat with the message if only it was
district 69 I know I know and Vijay
alluru with a 50 Super Chat I really
very very much appreciate that and all
of the great people that are here all
right let's continue with more things
that are going on breaking breaking
breaking we we have launched the Pacman
Finance Channel there are only two
videos on the channel
uh how to basically save and optimize
various accounts and how to choose an
asset allocation okay these are
non-political this is the new channel
youtube.com pacmanfinance you can get in
on the ground floor only
1650 subscribers on this channel this is
brand brand new
uh get in as one of the first 2 000
subscribers why not
that's youtube.com pacmanfinance many
people demanded it uh
uh
Jewish Finance tips
we may want to ban for that moderators
please determine whether we should be
banning for Jewish Finance tips I don't
I don't know about that it's a little
bit edgy it's a little bit edgy uh 1700
look at that they're climbing very very
quickly but we have a bunch of Clips
scheduled we have a clip coming out on
Pacman Finance about uh interest rates
we have one about inflation we have one
about uh index funds all of these
different things okay so it's really
really exciting stuff and member
subscriptions are dumping in very very
quickly let's continue I have another
very important new release this is an
audio release this is from casual divide
this is one of our viewers if anybody in
the audience is interested in making a
music video for this new song this is a
um this is a version of our theme song
that has been done by casual divide I
think it's really good take a listen
[Music]
there's a story
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
if anybody can put a video accompaniment
to it that's that's good we'll put it as
one of our one of our introductions I
think that'll be really really great
okay we're going to move on to some
other politics but I just have to clean
out the computer because I have so many
things here that have stacked up over
time this is a view that I have found to
be very accurate about using Yelp to
find the best Chinese restaurants I want
you to listen very carefully to what
Freddie Wong claims here I think this is
genius okay listen to this the easiest
way to find authentic Chinese food
assuming you're living in a major
metropolitan area is to go on Yelp and
look for restaurants with three and a
half Stars exactly three and a half not
three not four three and a half stars is
a sweet spot for authentic Chinese food
PF Chang's two and a half Stars bad
obviously obviously bad disaster I mean
you shouldn't be caught dead at a PF
Chang's in Tai Fung four stars too many
stars too many white people like it the
service is too good the food's not as
good as it could be the dumplings here
are better I've been here the waiters
are not going to pay attention to you
they're going to be rude but it's gonna
taste better that's what I'm talking
about three and a half stars that orange
3.5 that's exactly what you want why
this is exactly my experience my
experience on this is the best dumpling
houses I've found the best you know some
of the best Chinese food I have found
are places that the Locale is not
upscale the service is fine they're not
like oh excuse me sir how is it is there
anything is it acceptable they're just
going to bring you the food okay they'll
look a little bit annoyed when you order
fine but the food is fantastic and what
I find when I look later on Yelp they
have three and a half stars and people
kind of like complain about the service
or they say it wasn't the but the food
is absolutely fantastic I think this is
couldn't be more accurate couldn't be
more accurate and by the way I hate to
tell you this if you go in and the
um the the clientele is all Caucasian
it's probably not that good of a place I
mean is it you know you want a place
that's good enough
that chat if it's a Chinese restaurant
that Chinese folks are saying this is
the place to go
um yeah and I'm also not looking to chat
with the servers I I completely agree
with you fuzzy no no question about it
so I like this perspective a lot I think
it's really really smart all right let's
get to a couple of other things actually
let's go backwards here is Charlie Kirk
with a very strange declaration he says
he wears makeup when he goes on TV but
that men shouldn't actually wear makeup
it's really weird first of all let me
say that I do wear makeup only when I'm
on television so I want to make sure I
make that very clear I don't wear makeup
otherwise if I wasn't gonna be in front
of Bright Lights actually don't have any
on today but if I go on cable TV in
those Bright Lights you do need a little
bit of powder by the way I am not
understanding how it is that Charlie
Kirk's head keeps getting smaller but
his face keeps getting bigger it's
it really should be studied
quite frankly okay but I think Tom what
you're pointing towards and what I would
tell your daughter and one day what I
will tell mine is what kind of man do
you want to marry
and if you wish to marry a man that
wears makeup and acts feminine
and I think that probably needs some
loving adjustment and confrontation God
made the masculine and The Feminine they
are meant for one another and what's
with all the facial Twitches anybody
know that just everything about this is
really weird there's a whole deeper
discussion about makeup and about why
women wear makeup and there are some
people that are very strict in Christian
circles that say you shouldn't wear
makeup at all I completely disagree with
that I think there's actually been some
very thoughtful Christian biblical
commentary on that but just more broadly
than that let's just say this that if
you have a dude that is wearing makeup
yeah they need to be confronted and say
that's wrong why don't you just unless
you're on TV in which case Charlie also
you know wears it himself is it isn't
this just a strange thing it's all very
very weird he's getting glitchy yeah I
want to say thanks to a bunch of really
great people uh including nug Wrangler
McStuff Kathy face plant kaggers Jonesy
amunden and Rich bird Nation signing up
via twitch that puts us at 171 over on
the website I want to say thanks to
Angela Martinelli as well as Lisha
Mendez who signed up and got beautiful
memberships on my website and then
thanks also to stennett for Senate for
gifting a membership and Juan for
gifting a membership putting us at 175
we've already locked in a Friday Trump
rally stream 250 is our goal to lock in
the first debate stream after that which
would be the Beto versus Abbott debate
which I think is going to be absolutely
extraordinary
absolutely extraordinary let's continue
next clip there was a heated exchange
this troll Alex Stein Alex Stein is the
guy I don't know how many of you
remember Alex Stein quote confronted AOC
by saying how she's I think the term he
used was like wasn't it like big booty
latina or something like that completely
horrible misogynistic video where AOC
had to sort of be redirected Away by one
of her aides he's just an instigator an
agent provocateur
he then confronted Dan Crenshaw and it
became quite heated this was a few days
ago
look you're too slow
hey seriously an ABC it's funny Dan how
you said you're talking I'm small but
I'm so much taller than you Dan
I'm so much bigger than you
you're just a little you're a little sad
little boy
I'm the little one
yeah imagine me calling you Crenshaw is
disgusting but Alex Stein is also
discussed like they're both disgusting
yeah because you're not you're a
globalist oh I got a job I worked for
the place I gotta make a lot of money
globalished yeah I do yeah I do Dan yeah
I make a lot of money yeah I'm a loser
we're a pleasure this is the guy this is
the guy who tells veterans that they're
about their services yeah yeah because
those are weapons of mass destruction
anti-war yeah
how many followers does this guy have
278 wow oh he's on Blaze as a matter of
fact he did oh where was Oh What weapons
of mass destruction you're actually
going to go down this route yeah
you guys Services
I I have to tell you
Stein is really good at getting people
Furious like I I find everything he does
completely disgusting but he is so
irritating so irritating that he seems
very effective at uh getting a rise out
of people what about America so you're a
globalist why don't you take care oh my
goodness did you guys see that spit bomb
look at look closely there's a huge spit
bombs about America so you're a
globalist why don't you take her there
is I think I can even isolate that let
me see if I can find that hold on that's
a wild spit bomb
let me see if I can I think it's right
oh it's like too too quick almost you
can see a line of spit right there
that's just the that's the leftover
there's like one of those strings what
are those strings by the way I never
understood what those Springs are
strings
um let's see if there's another moment
no okay tell us about America so you're
a globalist why would you take
it you don't care about Texas
is there an invasion on our border right
maybe you should go back is there an
invasion you're gonna admit if there's
an invasion on our voice
in Ukraine why do you give 80 billion to
Ukraine uh I think you're getting the
numbers wrong there buddy oh what do we
had 100 million now no it's not even
cool oh what are we up to now Dan and
they even say none of those weapons even
go to the front lines so once you start
caring about America absolutely you
don't care about America at all Dan
you're a globalist you're a Trader
you're a dwarf there's Dan Crenshaw
I mean my view is let him fight these
are both horrible people who do nothing
good for the country it really is a lot
of fight
come on dude
you're the one that's a global you're
killing young children for no reason
you know I think people are asking in
the chat how I would handle if this guy
approached me honestly if this guy
approached me I think I would just look
at him and say
why are you talking like that is that
your real voice
and then I would just leave it at that
and just not even indulge it anyway I
think that that would be my instinct
Ure
am I under arrest
now do people know the um
do people know whether in Washington DC
it's a so-called stop and identify
because that's a whole other thing where
let's see police can stop you if they
have reasonable suspicion that you're
involved in a crime oh wow so this guy
I'm actually surprised since it appears
as though DC is not a stop and identify
state
um he could have actually done the whole
what crime are you suspecting me of uh
if you can't if you can't explain what
that is I don't even I don't even
actually have to provide ID but he chose
it looks like he chose not to do that
I'm just letting you know from what we
were getting from members of the public
was that you were harassing members that
were trying to go back and forth to
their votes you were not allowed to do
that so I'm going to let you know the
rules and the laws that you are
told that you were breaking and I'm
going to let you know that that's what
you cannot do okay am I allowed to leave
you are allowed to leave okay thank you
thank you this is just trying to ask
politicians some questions and then they
come anyway so super annoying guy
everything everything about him is very
very annoying thanks to micro Kimmy and
Aunt Fufu as well as Kindle lover Silo
just gifted five subscriptions on Twitch
adding eight and then uh that puts us at
183 over on the website I want to say
thank you to Mary Moreno who just signed
up at joinpakman.com and his new member
number 184 let's continue because we
have so many other things to look at
Dave Rubin
said something very very strange about
his kids I guess let's take a listen to
this two years old he's in first grade
imagine if five six years old he's in
first grade imagine if I found out that
actually for three months there was a
teacher okay I'm being told that the
Capitol Police do have stop and identify
jurisdiction even though DC is not stop
and identify okay getting to him about
gender or sexuality maybe calling him
Justine instead of Justin and I didn't
know about that
I might kill that person
talking about we're gonna have to go
back and listen to that did he say if
the teacher calls his kid by a different
name he might kill the teacher do I
understand is that actually what he said
we're going to listen to that again I
did just notice that s Prez gifted
another 69 subscriptions putting us at
uh wait 16
253 which is an incredible incredible
number let's we have now locked in the
Beto versus
Abbott debate the next stream on the
table is September 1 Trump rally okay if
we get to 300 we will lock in the
September 1 Trump rally stream let's
listen again to this thing Dave Rubin
said I really want to make sure I'm
understanding it correctly six years old
he's in first grade imagine if I found
out that actually for three months there
was a teacher talking to him about
gender or sexuality maybe calling him
Justine instead of Justin and I didn't
know about that
I might kill that person
he is he does seem to be saying he would
kill the teacher if they so he's saying
if his son Justin I don't even does he
have his son named Justin
Is that real or is that not really
whatever it doesn't matter
if his son asked his teacher to call him
a girl's name
and the teacher did it
Reuben would kill the teacher is what
he's saying it sounds like
that's where we're at right so unless
you don't want these people killed and I
mean this somewhat
flippingly oh so he wouldn't kill them
okay
sorry October 1st for that stream stream
yeah I'm sorry October 1st is the Trump
rally sorry sorry
um
like it's they want to abuse children
they want to abuse children that is
abuse I don't mean that as overt sexual
abuse but it is an abusive so he would
kill them but not literally and it's
sexual abuse but not literally geez okay
um all right people are asking me for
the video of Trump's lawyers getting
heckled so let's just look at that Trump
lawyers heckled
let's see
hmm not seeing anything like that
Trump lawyers
uh
I'm not finding that if people can get
that to me
I will play it
but I am not finding that
okay so let's continue with a few other
things I do want to say thank you to
Alice and Octavian for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 255 and also
a big thank you to our great friend
Terry schweren who just gifted a
subscription on our website uh all very
very much appreciated okay let's look at
a couple of the speeches from the Texas
youth Summit this was really scary stuff
this is Lauren bobert speaking let's
just listen to a little bit of it and I
I acknowledge we may not be able to
tolerate that much of it
[Applause]
she's wearing a gun by the way if you
guys can't tell or maybe you can she's
wearing a gun
this is what freedom feels like now
Texas youth Summit let me hear what
freedom I don't know why she's screaming
she has a microphone
a standing ovation from the half empty
crowd although the kid is sitting thank
God for the kid huh
it is so awesome to be with you all you
are all so encouraging I travel all over
the United States to get people
energized about our future and about our
nation and today Texas youth Summit you
have reignited the passion in me to save
this country you guys are so incredible
freedom is what this is all about it's
what it's always been about freedom
was the vision that our founding fathers
had for our great nation
while our founding fathers were still
under
tyranny and oppression
they had a vision of Liberty
freedom
and they put their faith
to action Faith always has corresponding
actions faith without works is dead
and if you look at our founding fathers
everything that they did required Faith
the words that they spoke were the very
life-giving words of God and they didn't
so basically it seems like the speech is
making the case that the U.S should be a
theocracy a Christian a christian-based
theocracy
so I don't know do we need to listen to
more of it do people want to listen to
more do we go on to the next speaker
I could go either way but I can't
imagine we're going to learn anything
from this
everybody's good okay all right let's
continue to the next one
then we heard from these are in no
particular order Kaylee maganani spoke
let's listen to that one
[Music]
okay hi thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
all right the crowd has filled in a
little bit more for Kaylee
well what an honor to be back at the
Texas youth Summit I was here with you
guys in Conroe last time last year
um and Christian wasn't that a great
time that day Collins he does such a
remarkable job let's give him a round of
applause
[Applause]
not just hosting the Texas youth Summit
but what he has done and is doing for
the conservative movement uh what he's
doing for young people who have an
interest in conservatism uh it's
remarkable so it's an honor to be here
at Christian Collins conservatism now
basically means saying vaccines are bad
and that the guy who lost by 8 million
votes actually won that's that's
conservatism in 2022. friends in the
Texas youth Summit and to some people
JFK and or JFK Jr are still alive
they're not even sure which one is which
sometimes
you know a lot has changed since I was
at the White House the
press briefings are very different
and I don't know if you watch them yeah
they're boring the way they're supposed
to be probably not I watched a few of
them because I have to and I do it on
your behalf so that you don't have to
the questions have changed quite a bit
in fact I brought a few of them here's
one of them that jensaki was asked this
was first day on the job first press
briefing one of the questions was could
you give us some color about what it was
like for Joe Biden going into the Oval
Office he's been waiting for this for so
long
wow never Trump got questions Trump
Trump's First Press Secretary Sean
Spicer also got silly softballs on the
first day I mean that's and then Spicer
decided to lie about the crowd I got a
question like that who would have been
nice
uh then there was Will Donald Trump keep
the Air Force or excuse me well
President Biden keep Donald Trump's Air
Force One color scheme because all the
American people were wondering that
question but they asked that can you
clarify for us what happened with the
president's dog there's been some
reports that there's a biting incident
again really pressing issue my personal
favorite can you give us an update on
the White House cat
really good stuff I'm pretty sure that
those were like one-off questions four
of them that came during the first like
six months of the presidency
and you know
anyway
um rewind okay all right I think we're
done with Kaylee so that's good now
we've got Ted Cruz so if you really were
waiting for something more vomitous
uh it's gonna be hard to top Ted Cruz
let me just say a quick thank you to
Shauna Blackburn who just gifted a
subscription at joinpakman.com putting
us at 257 at 300 we lock in another live
stream I want to say thanks also to
scrut scamander and rookie putting us at
259 with their twitch Prime
subscriptions let's listen oh hold on a
few super chats Discman says David sir
hold on sure sure
David sir I always wanted to tell you
that my girlfriend showing me your
videos is what pulled me away from the
Republican Party
thank you for all that you do well thank
you Discman or Discman and very good
usage of the correct your which is rare
it's rare James says David sir sure sure
I am coming to you with tears in my eyes
requesting as many Trump sound drops as
you can play in a row especially theft
cephahide well I'm not going to do that
um but I will do a couple I don't need
oh here it is
[Music]
Ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps I'd
be dating her supposing we hit the body
with a tremendous uh very powerful light
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times all right Larry says hey David a
friend recently showed me the Q Anon
Anonymous YouTube channel have you seen
it some of the craziest stuff I've seen
I have not seen that I should probably
review that off stream first
um an incredibly powerful gift from s
Prez just dumped in 69 subscriptions
putting us at 3 28 which is
extraordinary
extraordinary number also thank you to
Nicholas Van Dusen for signing up on my
website number 329 let's get into the
Ted Cruz Insanity God Bless Texas
[Applause]
and God bless the poor beleaguered
impoverished citizens of Martha's
Vineyard
it is incredible to be with you
I'm here tonight
to give you a word of encouragement give
you a word of Hope
hard to find a more inspirational
speaker than Ted Cruz so he's the
perfect guy to do it
I've got two very simple points
the first one
is America is in crisis
what's happening right now this isn't
normal
that's true president of the United
States who shakes hands with the empty
air widely debunked I already talked
about that with you guys
we have a president who talks to the
Easter Bunny
it's weird that honestly I hope this
isn't defensive guys
but when Ted Cruz says we have a
president that talks to the Easter Bunny
George Bush said God spoke to him and
told him to invade Iraq
isn't that way more consequential and
bonkers
like is it offensive to say it to point
that out
Bush said he prayed and God told him to
do the invasion
and then hundreds of thousands of people
died
I don't know and I gotta say under Joe
Biden everything
and I mean everything has gone wrong
some ways it's actually kind of amazing
to mess every single policy up
I mean you think if they rolled I like
that Ted Cruz was able to both get a
horrible pattern for his suit jacket and
for it to be completely ill-fitting like
a lot of times
you get one or the other
but Ted Cruz has been able to do both
the dice something they'd get right
but you got inflation sky
cost of every
food going up costs the rent going up
costs of lumber cost of homes cost of
electricity cost of Health Care will you
mention gas
cost of gasoline but wait that's been
down for 100 days in a row
it's so bad antifa can't afford bricks
oh is this oh is this a comedy routine
oh I didn't know that
oh bad
well can't afford Chinese dinners
it is so bad
that AOC can't afford fake handcuffs
then we have crime rates skyrocketing
murder rates through the roof carjacking
through the roof
foreign
chaos in American cities across the
country
we have illegal immigration the worst
rate of illegal immigration in 62 years
and as bad as the economic and domestic
policy
all right anyways
man I don't think I can keep going yeah
it's a real what's the deal with airline
food moment I I completely agree with
you guys yeah
really really really strange stuff
um all right let's see who else spoke
here is oh Marjorie Trader green I guess
just in in order to be thorough we
should listen to a little bit of that
well this looks like a good way to spend
a Friday night
oof
uh uh man
real Dog the Bounty Hunter Vibes no this
is a perfect way to spend a Friday night
because we have a lot to talk about
right I mean there are a lot of things
going on
so I was putting together my notes and
thinking about what do I want to talk
about it the Texas youth Summit and then
I thought you know I really should
explain to everyone here what Congress
is like you know I'm new to Congress it
feels like I've been there for about
maybe 40 or 50 years just like Nancy
Pelosi
but I haven't I mean it's not even been
two years I'm a freshman member of
Congress
and on track to accomplish nothing I'd
never served in government before never
never was elected never held any kind of
position we know as a matter of fact I
was pretty
pretty living my great perfect American
life that's like a trump thing to be
like you know you people are lucky I'm
even here I could have been doing way
better things than this my life was
great before I got involved with all
this stuff that's a real that's a real
Trump move but you know what you can
only live in the United States of
America
but I got sick and tired of leaders in
Washington trying to ruin everything
so I ran for Congress and now I'm a
member of Congress and I was thinking
okay how can I explain what Congress is
like I'm going to go ahead and tell you
guys it's a lot like High School
it really is
I mean you know how in school you've got
that person in your class and they're
they sit close to you and then they
quietly pass gas and you're like
you're like is that that same kid
and they never own it or apologize or
anything this is a weird story what
Nadler you know Jerry Nadler right
over and sit kind of in our area and he
does the same thing
and it's really gross that I'm like God
Jerry Nadler this is really weird you
guys
this is really really weird
midnight in college and you're creaming
for a test and you're studying and
you're trying to get ready and prepared
for for your test or your exam or a
report or writing a paper it's hard for
me to imagine Marjorie did any of those
things but okay and so you're up till
one or two o'clock in the morning
well guess what Nancy Pelosi will keep
us in the house chamber voting sometimes
until one or two o'clock in the morning
we never start the day early like most
people when you go to work or school you
know at normal times like maybe eight
o'clock in the morning no that never
happens and I couldn't figure out why
and I'm like well maybe it's just
because they're kind of night creatures
like witches and vampires and ghouls
laughs
okay all right I guess the the funny
part is about to start or has ended I
don't know let's look at this is the
last one I'll subject you guys to this
is Candace Owens
what's up Texas
[Applause]
so good to see you guys it's so good to
be back I love you
you
guys have a seat man so great to be back
in the great state of Texas I am here a
lot it is one of my favorite States
definitely probably maybe my favorite
state right
let's see Kim Kardashian's having a bad
week I've seen this uh you know people
are commenting and seeing this video of
me going viral discussing this
unbelievable cultural moment in which we
realize that her own mother
intentionally released a sex tape about
her they decided to do this for fame
and a lot of people ask
a lot of people ask you know why who
cares about this stuff why do we comment
on culture why yeah okay we offer
commentary on culture why do we follow
culture well it's because it's time for
Counter Culture which is you know being
Christian having values having decency
having morals to respond and to
recognize evil where it stands right it
was Andrew Breitbart that said that
politics is Downstream from culture and
he was correct the things that we're
seeing today and the things that we're
fighting about really an electric
speaker
um it's all because the left seized
Hollywood and the left one culture and
conservatives just allowed them to it's
why there's nobody on the you're not
allowed to be um a conservative and in
Hollywood they'll chase you out of there
right it's because they know how
important it is to seize so just to like
do our or let's skip ahead 10 minutes
just to see if it's all this bad because
we only listen to the first few minutes
of each of these Pages just to see if it
takes them a while to get into the good
stuff or the substance I've skipped
ahead nine minutes let's see thing there
is no society that can survive without
strong men
oh God it seems it actually gets worse
now but a side aside from hating men I
mean aside from hitting men they also
hate women right so when they see a
woman and she looks happy and she looks
like she's showered right because their
new thing is like I'm not shaving my
armpits that's about the patriarchy I'm
like okay I I basically
basically every woman I know is is
liberal
and they all shave their armpits
like what what are they even talking
about yes right they're shaving their
heads okay I don't know any women who
have shaved their heads they want to
look like dudes if you don't like me
because I'm stinky you know I have
purple hair it's because the patriarchy
and it's like no it's because you're
stinky like you stink that's why I don't
like you right common sense
um but if they develop this Persona
which is like we they have to be super
ugly and if you don't like them it's
your fault and they make themselves
unbeautiful and they see a happy woman a
woman that is confident in her own skin
a woman that is pursuing family and
productive relationships a woman that
aspires to have children a woman that
wants to raise her children by the way
the toughest job in the world is to be a
good mother
toughest job in the world
so why shouldn't the government help
people doing the toughest job in the
world
when they see that they hate that and
they attack it so you've got these
radical feminists you've got Greta
thundberg you've got the bathroom signs
that are somehow making people
what is Greta tunberg have to do with
any of this that I don't understand
cry and you just look up sometimes and
you go am I crazy or is the world crazy
right I'm like am I going crazy or like
is everybody just being a super extra
insane and the answer by the way that
Dennis Prager gave me he said you know
the left just likes chaos the left is
after is just chaos you have to
understand that there there is no you
know
none of this is interesting it doesn't
this it's terrible it's truly terrible
it doesn't make any sense thanks to
Salty butt chugger as well as Wookie
Jack Lil neezy and fjorkum for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
333
333 the big big news today Donald Trump
sued and criminally referred to the IRS
that's the big news I am glad to have
been able to share that information with
you today that is going to do it for
today's short stream the streams are
back my friends I will see you back here
in 48 hours for the next Trump rally
then we'll have the Beto Abbott debate
and more and more and more make sure
that you are subscribed to the Pacman
Finance Channel we added about six uh
300 subscribers just during the stream
we do have live Clips like comment
subscribe on the two clips please watch
like and comment hit the Subscribe
button we are building the personal
finance channel from the ground up from
the ground up look there's another 10
dumping in very powerfully
uh can we even get to 2000 that would be
a beautiful thing I can't tell you how
excited I am about the new channel
everything else keeps going and we will
see everybody very very soon
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is Trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample Trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
thank you
big massive dumps
dumps dumps
[Music]